alter komme junge ich habe noch nie so
um menschen erlebt du bist der dümmste
teilnehmer den dieses projekt besitzen
kann
hallöchen freuen und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge minecraft captain
jazz combo
das war die folge freute das war vor der
nächste folgerichtige rausholen ich habe
keine spitze hatten selbstverständlich
das ist aber sehr nett da ja du bist ja
er hat den stein um abbauen das ist ja
das dauert ein bisschen
helft ihr mal gleich eben schnell
dadurch ist die folge bei mir dauert
noch nicht mehr lange die folge über
opel
mein erfolg ist eine sache vergessen du
penner alter tötest du mich denn da für
die ewigkeit gebaut hast dich level wkk
mal du bist spitze lösung sprich bist
tot
aber es war glaube ich mir jetzt seine
spitzhacke die habe ich mir verdient so
der verdienen weil er mich getötet hat
nee da befreit aber aus dieser lage wo
du mich ein gebaut hast hast du mich wie
wir sie bisher herausgekommen
ich hab mich hoch gesteckt da konnte ich
nach oben weg hier unten geht die action
also wenn du es einfach unter ich
brauche meine spitzhacke ja irgendwie
auch mal wir müssen diese steine weg ich
habe in der letzten folge ganzen raum
ist ein bisschen schöner gemacht fragt
wo das herkommt und wir wollen jetzt
wieder einigermaßen wirtschaftsmanager
fordern china freundlich zu einer neuen
bringt das ja alles nicht mehr am uns
nämlich eigentlich gar nichts
vorgenommen wir wollten ich wollte mal
guckt ob das zuckerrohr um rollt es auch
wegen der kuh mal gucken und man hört
bei mir gar nichts oha alte jetzt ist
sie schon wieder was explodiert ich
brauche ich meine spitzer gedrückt dass
auch fackeln von mir du hast alles von
mir
die halle ist eingeworfen
hier vorstufe engel die austria-adler
co2 die stücke die behalte ich harry das
sicher dass die behalten ein ok kommen
würde ich heute auf jeden fall mal nach
der kuh um nach der verschollenen stimmt
uns wurde nämlich häufig in die
kommentare geschrieben dass wir die kuh
irgendwo eingesperrt hätten
ich weiß es nicht ab jetzt nur ich
versage das jetzt wenn ich aufnehme
guckst du kurz nach der kuh und landen
in der nächsten folge wenn du aufnimmst
guck ich noch der kunst immer so weiter
bis diese gefunden haben weil ich wollte
jetzt mal ganz ganz oben beim zucker
rock und persönlich glaube lange wird es
nicht dauern ich kann mir schon gut
vorstellen
also ich glaube ich weiß wohl allemal
woran der baum wo man der held namens
eingang die suche nach dieses hinter
leitern die suche nach der verschollenen
q1 gewachsen
fabry und brillant hammer hammer hammer
hammer
drei stück habe ich super dann plötzlich
die mal eben hier wieder an so was nur
darin dass ein nächstes mal getötet zum
beispiel liebe nicht alter conny was
hast du okay das ist ja mit den hühnern
los bitte warum sind denn da für viele
am baden baden
denn ist wohl auch ein bischen reis
schaltet man hier ohne witz roja gras ja
unser wer mich ja richtig gemacht
das hat man ja ich glaube ich war ja
auch immer wann immer ich glaube wo wann
dann nun eingang von uns hat das war
doch hier der alte oder was wir als
höhen gang runter hier entdeckungsreise
das ist doch spannend entdeckungsreise
ja ich bin unterwegs ich muss nochmal
antonia schon die ganzen bin ich am
rumpf ist eine vernünftige zeit kommt
aber mit
das ist wasser alter höhleneingang
gemacht bevor jetzt noch das schwein mit
komm mach ich wieder zu so ich hier soll
die kuh eng wir ein saal gelaufen sein
haben wir nie irgendwas gebaut was es
ankommt zuschauer wieder unser neuer
sehr ganz normale weg halten unser alter
lenker oder mainz war meinte kohl würde
stellen wenn die von darunter springt
nein auf keinen fall
nicht bei so einer höhe nehmen denke ich
auch nicht verantwortlich da ist so
wichtig da habe ich dich eingebaut hat
und das können wir auch mal ganz kurz
weg machen
das ist ja wirklich aus ja echt mal
hertha wo können ich habe mich schon die
ganze zeit gefragt wo hätten mit
einsperren können wir haben noch nie so
viele
na ja doch beim alten höhen eingang aber
haben wir ja gerade geschaut
anscheinend ist der cache und es gibt
auch mehr als drei diamanten hier auf
der karte aber hier habe ich mal das
zugebaut warte ich glaube hier war das
war auch keine kurier wir werden noch
nie haben so viele leute geschrieben
das ist irgendwo sein muss wir würden
doch nur hören ohne witz wenn ich jetzt
auch keine kuh weil ich ich höre keinen
mut ist die fläche tod brauchen tages
nicht die darf nicht in eine kuh kann
nicht sterben
sie kann niemals sterben oder ein
schwert auf keinen fall niemals geht
niemals nie romy merkte dass aber wir
wären ja heute erst mal wahrscheinlich
den zauber tisch machen oder oder wasser
mir vor heute
ich weiß nicht das ist ein bisschen blöd
weil wir haben ja erst drei zucker euch
habt jetzt wieder angepflanzt war da
sagen kann man ja eine spinne häckseln
hexe o
damit kann man doch auch ok ich hab'
trank okay die glasflasche nur schade
das wären wir auch schon
ja da wäre vielleicht meinen die diese
kuh ihr optikur eingesperrt gefunden
ja die die bei uns oben steht vielleicht
machen die das mit einem gespräch ich
hoffe nicht
das wäre aber echt peinlich ich bin
giftig irgendwas los wird am liebsten
grad nochmal in den kommentaren gucken
aber ich weiß noch ganz genau dass da
welche geschrieben im jahr bei eurem
höhleneingang habt ihr die damals
eingesperrt die muster und nirgendwo
seien irgendwie sowas haben die damals
in die kommentare geschrieben
ja dann auch so gedacht hey das hätten
wir hätten doch nie im leben eine kuh
eingesperrt oder also na ja na ja wir
hatten glaube ich also ich weiß noch wie
wir beide damals relativ schnell den
höhleneingang dazu gemacht hatten ich
kann mir halt gut vorstands die kohle
rein gelaufen ist
aber mehr kann ich mir auch nicht
vorstellen ja doch ne kuh
ich kann das eigentlich nicht vorstellen
die ist irgendwie die partie kann ich
alles weg sagt ja das haben wir dann
auch dass die länder nicht ist die kann
ja eigentlich auch nicht einfach mal so
weg sei dies wahrscheinlich in saint
portal gelaufen ist geht in ordnung
mops kommen dadurch oder java kommt dass
ein portal ist noch offen aber das lama
aber ja gut ich hätte überall in laaber
fallen können also ich hab ja wir
brauchen auf jeden fall eine kuh ich
weiß gar nicht ob er eine tief mit
schnee für leder und wofür brauchen wir
lieder für bücher für die verzauberung
strisch echt der nivea leder in der tour
ich hoffe wir das noch nicht verwendet
ich hatte doch mal ausleihen truhe oben
in der luft leder bekommen klaus kleine
schau mal kurz nach ich komme auch mal
wieder hoch irgendwie wird wer es hier
wir haben zehn üblich hier unten
wir haben
15 leder haben wir alter fünf leder kann
schon wohl wie verlierst du denn damals
in der dings in der was in der truhe
drei leder oder so habe ich das gefunden
glaube ich ich junge ohne witz ich kann
jetzt nicht mehr hin
dann kommen die anderen leder
wahrscheinlich von nicht von getöteten
kuhn ein dass eventuell auch aus einer
anderen tue
eine quoten wieder mal am anfang getötet
ja ja daher kommt noch zwei leder dann
die anderen trainer aus hunden erstmals
klar zu stellen
du hast du getötet dass mein rad zu
stellen
es ist völlig wurscht ich könnte auch
gleich die andere kurve 0 man das ist
doch wir müssen hier irgendwie mal ich
gewehr nach oben in die luft das schau
ich mal ob ich irgendwie was übersehen
haben oder sogar neuen goldnuggets
moment ja das noch welche man das kann
nicht sein das gibt's ja noch fällig
wenn sie wir machen können ja dann schon
herrmann wir können doch wofür brauchen
wir leder für das buch wir können uns
den kuchen machen dem macher dafür
brauchen wir weizen das haben wir zucker
kennen gleich von zuckerrohr milch
kringe von der q a haben wir auch genug
geld auf jeden fall eine zum ich schaue
mal ganz großen kuchen crafted er macht
das mal nie und dann denk mal weiter
denkmal der zauber tisch geht doch auch
ihr mann braucht obsidian blatt papier
das ging ja nicht doch klar zuckerrohr
wir haben doch nur drei und davon
brauche ich zwei für zucker und das
andere muss noch weiter wachsen
extra wieder ja es stimmt ja heute
schaffen wir es nicht mehr klar denken
können wir können noch viele erfolge in
zukunft machen aber jetzt erst mal ich
mach mal ganz eben kurz den kuchen
ach so ein 1 3 1 früh alter wir brauchen
drei eimer
wir haben uns zwar reichte hast du noch
reisen
nie habe ich eine tour wege liegt jetzt
kann also noch länger true gold ist dass
wir haben gar keinen alten als ob
achtung pick zombie von oben
er ist auf unserer plattform gestaltern
ein mit jetzt fehlt es uns an einem
wendepunkt wir können doch dann später
wieder links und wie das kleiner und
denken mit komplexen weise 23 ich suche
jetzt erhält wenn man bitte dass wir
ihnen die eisen finden und ich bin ganz
oben
ich bin ganz ganz okay dann suche ich
alleine eben also hast du wirklich kein
alten arbeitest du dir sicher bin mir
hundertprozentig sicher
walter ich will diesen ich will diesen
fakten zaubert ich jetzt mal hinkriegen
ja weil er so klein und ich habe mich
nicht um sie gekümmert da hinten wieder
antrieb angelaufen
wieso geht er denn hoch ich hab doch so
oft auf den kopf geschlagen
das schlagzeug bass und zombie da schon
spiel auch man wohl fürs töten der
zombies hier oben schießenden bekommt
als ob er aber warum sind die sonst hier
oben ich schaue mir schon die ganze zeit
ob irgendwo diese scheiß kuh ist die
scheiß kuh
das ist eine richtige spur oh ja ich
hasse diese kuh weiter das kann doch
nicht sein dass es einfach eine kuh
stibitzt das habe ich auch schon so oft
gesagt das kann nicht sein dass er weg
ist gegen mainz war immer alle wo ist
die denn blabla ist da und da ich glaub
mir ich habe jetzt mal meine koordinaten
hier an
jetzt sagt mal gleich also ihr könnt ja
sagen okay wenn ich was hier drunter ist
die irgendwo dann schreibt uns einfach
die koordinaten die könnte die
koordinaten oben links lesen
schreibt uns einfach so oder welche
minute in dem video da wo wir am
nächsten dran
und alles mögliche von ein paar dinge
halt die uns weiterhelfen könnten erst
werde ich gut dass wir den top also sein
können wir nach gucken wo also ich kann
es auch ehrlich gesagt sonst sonst gar
nicht glauben wie ich das sehe ich jetzt
vor mir habe ich glaube das auch nicht
das wie eine kuh eingesperrt haben alter
wie dumm sind wir denn wer spät damit
die kühe ein mann ich werd wir brauchen
wirklich nur drei eisen für diesen
scheiß einmal guck mal nach ob du nicht
wirklich irgendwo noch eisen findest
oder so erst mal mache ich jetzt die das
schiff mit dem skelett hier ist grad 1
aber da 100pro liegt das natrue da unten
cook nach 100pro cook nach ich habe mir
gleich wiederkommen alter ich brauche
ich höre und gerade alles ich brauche
mein eisenmann ich könnte jetzt ein
skelett astana gefallen alter ich dachte
schon mal komme ich da nicht lange ich
habe einfach die world border nicht
gesehen
dies aber ich krass auch die wird auch
einfach dunkler hier unten und nach oben
hin irgendwie also oben ist immerhin
finde ich ja vielleicht so wie regnet
gerade ja man ja ich suche die ganze
zeit nach eisen guck mal bitte jetzt
eben schnell in der kiste ich möchte
auch einmal in meiner folge ging was
schaffen und das skelett ist nicht
gestorben mit einem pfeiler ich guck
direkt nach ich finde einfach nichts
es sind einfach nichts gefunden
ich finde wieder kohle vielleicht ist
das ja hier bei der kohle irgendwo sein
draht dran auch nicht komme doppelspitze
in diesem projekt vergab durch ein
rätsel
doch anstatt dranbleiben doch keiner
habe ich gemacht damit ich eben schnell
nach deine blöde eisen gucken können ja
super
das ist gut dass du dich zwei hinter
sich da bin ich richtig gut drin hey
guck mal ob es dazu die habe ich ja toll
aber ich brauchte was für ein mann
gebt mir doch mal was jetzt hier ihr
verdammten kaka brandl gold ja gold vivo
hier oben gerade auf unserer koppel der
kelag grad gold von dem kombi pitman
wahrscheinlich auch und ich habe zucker
wo er habe ich zucker lag ihr euch haben
drauf okay aber dem jahr schade hätte
der frühe gefundene krake wie kann das
weitläufige zucker ja ich habe gerade
zwei zucker rohrzucker gemacht damit ich
den kuchen machen kann ich wirklich dass
da oben was drauf lag
egal es ist viel wichtiger und laster
score bitte wachsen
das brauchen wir noch viele bücher und
so okay so ich schaue jetzt mal eben
schnell guckt ganz ganz schnell die
folge ist ein schon wieder zu ende
ich gehe ganz ganz schnell so da ist
doch sie reisen.com hoch dann gebe ich
den sie weisen backofen
wo ist schon alles fertig ist schon
fällig hab nur noch ärzte guckt euch
vollidiot die zuhause geben sich nur so
facebook von crafter und ich suchte
unten alles nachlesen
bis tod kommt bitte nicht hoch alter
alltag alter alltag alter was hast du
getan komme reisen dann die was hast du
getan mit der kuh jetzt haben die total
verschlissen
jetzt kann ich ja nicht mal mehr milch
holen für den kuchen alter junge ich hab
noch nie sondern menschen erlebt du bist
der dümmste teilnehmer denen dieses
projekt besitzen kann
es besteht aus zwei teilen das break
du bist der dümmste vorstand darauf
geschlagen
das ist ausgewichen werden du schlägst
du nicht auf das gelernt wenn eine kuh
steht was unsere einzige wir sind am
arsch wir sind rascher alter gleich
wollte ja darum wollte ich da wollte ich
was vernünftiges machen da bin ich jetzt
echt ich habe jetzt den eimer ich müsste
jetzt nur noch dass die milch geholt
habe und dann hätte ich mir ein buch
machen können und ich konnte macht alles
zunichte
alles komme man ja cool arschloch man
jetzt kann ich mein kuchen nicht button
alter ja wenn man kann sich hier niemand
bei mir geht immer alles kaputt ohne
witz in gómez folgen schaffe ich den
erfolg und dann geht das land kombi
nicht da wieder gute sachen und blabla
und komme macht auch voll für gute
sachen ja oder bei mir das archiv der
gibt stirbt einfach tausendmal ich
könnte heulen aber sie ist positiv wir
haben viel hühnchen
wir sehen unsere nächsten folge morgen
wieder mit schießereien die schirme war
wirklich ein versehen und das skelett
hätte einfach dort nicht lange laufen
dürfen